[Music]
cruisin was ready oh well hurry up
or else this princess is going to leave
for another castle
oh I know Mario expert but isn't luigi a
little more green whoa
Walter what are you doing what duplicate
stay away from me
oh yeah I did yeah
when I suggested Mario May I didn't mean
dress up like the Mario Brothers
oh come on Heather what's wrong with
getting in touch with our Italian roots
that is wrong on so many levels
oh no a second something's missing
[Music]
there we go now where's Ana my name is
Walter benezia
for months I was trapped in the evil
Dino Rob's Dynel dimension a place where
I was duplicated dozens of times
eventually I managed to escape but now
died rob is sending his army to take me
back with the help of my friends he
fight them off and hope to ultimately
take down mr. rage dinosaur then won't
we countdown the weaker he gets this is
top five the Super Mario Bros movie is
perhaps the most well known video game
to film adaptation failure ever it's at
least the most legendary released in
1993 this movie starred Bob Hoskins as
Mario John Leguizamo as Luigi and Dennis
Hopper as King Koopa well had the mario
bros name attached to it the film itself
was almost unrecognizable when compared
to the premise of the video games out at
the time it was a box-office bomb and
didn't even gross half its budget in
theaters while they failed to faithfully
translate the video games to the big
screen there was a lot of work done on
this movie particularly in the set
design the look of King Koopas
alternate-dimension wasn't anything like
the Mushroom Kingdom we knew and loved
but it's at least interesting to look at
with the 25th anniversary of this film's
release coming up at the end of the
month and a new animated Mario movie
being recently announced now is a great
time to look at the mistakes of the past
hopefully a better future for this
franchise is right around the corner
these are the top five worst Super Mario
Brothers movie moments
this is just one example of how the
characters in this movie are stupid
Oh after learning of his girlfriend's
abduction who by the way is totally not
Princess Peach Mario finally makes it
where she and the other missing New York
women are being held he sneaks in gets
his girlfriend's attention and is
compromised by this dummy it may seem
like a small thing but it's indicative
of bigger problems in this movie its
lack of smarter characters and lazy way
of getting out of difficult situations
speaks to how light on story and
character this film Willy was another
example of this is when Luigi makes all
the goombas dance in the elevator it's
like they wrote themselves into a hole
and just came up with something dumb to
get out of it to keep the film moving
but this is just blatant in how not
clever it is wouldn't it have been more
fun if Mario had to come up with a smart
way to get the girls out of there and
defeat the Goomba guard he could have at
least jumped on his head or something
you know like the game number four it's
clean it's dirty at the same time so
what were they going for in this scene
exactly it was pretty much a universal
disappointment that King Koopa was just
a regular human in this movie Dennis
Hopper was a legendary actor and while
he was a part of other stinkers in his
career
seeing him have to say lines like
plumber alert larry Lazard of Lazard
Lazard Conda dactyl is still strange to
this day he tried to make the character
your typical slimy bad guy and added
germophobia to his list of shortcomings
but there was also a touch of something
else that something else is on full
display in this weird mud bathing scene
I think my favorite part is as odd
delivery at the end the princess
the princess what the heck is this
supposed to be her spot maybe she ran
away because you made her dress up like
a fungus queen whatever number three
[Music]
Luigi Mario Daisy you gotta come with me
I need your help
what's wrong you never gonna believe
this or that this was meant to be a joke
or not having this little tease at the
end of the movie was laughable it was
almost as funny as them trying to
shoehorn the Super Mario Bros name in
there I call them the Super Mario
Brothers so a battle-torn Daisy comes
back in asking for Mario & Luigi's help
what was the sequel supposed to be about
the plumbers fighting evil carpenters
who turn out to be the hammer bros this
is an infamous scene that goes along
with other movies that set up a sequel
and never got one there's an after
credits scene too solidifying the pre
Marvel double-teams
the sope koopa cousins number two
[Music]
oh look everyone it's toad
can't you tell at this point in the
story the mario bros are down and out
they just had daisies meteorite piece
stolen from them are trapped in a Blade
Runner world covered in fungus and then
they run into walking exposition I know
toad explains things in the games but
even that's more subtle than this Mario
and Luigi looked like they just realized
they've entered hell I guess they're not
too far off you can go ahead and choke
this little Mushroom Kingdom
all you want close enough according to
history a long time ago big meteorite
came and blasted our universes into
parallel dimensions yeah no one else I
think all that fungus out there that's
our old king it's true and he's been
de-evolved that's right the plot of this
movie is its worst moment this is a
reacts planation of the opening
monologue but it's much worse because
toad is saying but hey great hand
motions buddy you'd think that they'd at
least try and hide the fact that they're
directly reminding the audience what's
going on but no mr. swirly skull is
basically reading off the back of the
DBB according to history a long time ago
big meteorite Cayden blasted our
universes into parallel dimensions and
all that fungus out there that's our old
king Freddy's bendy evolved into fungus
and now he's wreaking his revenge on the
city 1993 104 minutes directed by rocky
Morton and Annabelle Jake
the super mario bros movie is still
pretty terrible all these years later
but like a lot of you weaker up watching
it so while it sucks the top off a
mushroom it's still and will likely
always be the only live-action mario
movie now TV that's a whole other story
this week on my personal channel you can
catch me reminiscing about my earliest
mario memories and how I grew to love
him and his brother oh right know I'm
starting to get a little worried Ayana
would not miss a whole episode like this
hmm well I know one man who can help us
hey Jim have you seen Ayanna yeah when
your clone things took her about an hour
ago what and you didn't stop him
look I'm not responsible for looking
after you three every time you feel like
playing dress-up I've got more important
things to focus on than saving you from
rob every week now if you'll excuse me I
have some very important work to do
are you sure about this
if it really was one of my duplicates
there's only one place it would have
taken her oh you gotta be kidding me
she's in that dimension we have to go in
and get her back I thought you said
you'd never go in there again oh
definitely don't want to but what choice
do we have
all right let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
you